hallo leute ich sie teure mal waren und
willkommen im 2021 dem ersten video auf
meinem kanal es ist mir wirklich sehr
schwer gefallen mich für das erste video
zu entscheiden und da wir heute eh
kurieren barbecue essen dachte ich komme
das ist es carriern barbecue essen für
die seele deswegen begrüße ich euch ganz
herzlich zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt und heute fragen wir uns wie
schmeckt kurian barbecue und es ist
eigentlich ein richtiges wie schmeckt
weil es gibt so viele koreanische serien
auch netzwerk sowie green barbecue essen
[Musik]
ist bei denen nur barbecue
gegen italiener auch
ins italienische restaurants ich
fokussiere mich jetzt wieder aufs thema
und wir stellen uns erst mal die
wichtigsten fragen wie schmeckt nein
spaß was ist kurian barbecue grill and
barbecue ist sehr gesellig ähnlich wie
beim raclette bereitet man seine speisen
am tisch zu und ist während man koch in
den restaurants wo man dieses barbecue
essen kann sind die grille manchmal im
tisch integriert oder werden dazu
gestellt und damit es dort nicht
komplett verraucht ist gibt es über
jedem tisch eine dunstabzugshaube und
das sieht eigentlich auch mal ganz
lustig aus und gibt so richtig diesen
carrion barbecue flair traditionell
werden rind huhn oder schwein gegrillt
mariniert oder auch und mariniert das
bedeutet aber nicht dass man sich nicht
auch gemüse drauflegen kann wie bin ich
zu dieser besonderen speise gekommen
sorry es schneit so wunderschön vom
fenster das ist für alle fünf sekunden
ein mal rüber gucke und welche tätig wie
im winter wonderland zurück zur frage
war wies kennengelernt kelly hat uns in
new york in die welt des kurieren
barbecues eingeführt und als ich mir
dann zum ersten mal ein stück
mariniertes rindfleisch mit reis in
einem salat ball in den mund eingeführt
habe wusste ich das wird eine liebe wie
lange hält und bis heute würde ich diese
salat bombe mit dem marinierten
rindfleisch und ein bischen reis ein
bisschen soße vielleicht noch kimchi um
drauf als die spirituelle erfahrung
meines lebens beschreibt
[Musik]
aber muss jetzt nach korea oder new york
fliegen um das probieren zu können
nein es gibt auch viele koreanische
barbecue restaurants in deutschland ich
war schon in 2 in köln und in berlin ist
mein lieblingsrestaurant es es gibt auch
noch andere wie zum beispiel kimchi
princess da war ich aber noch nicht und
soul kitchen aber tatsächlich konnte ich
bis jetzt nur ssm ausprobieren und ich
fand so gut dass ich da glaube ich vier
oder fünfmal war aber ich glaube in
jeder stadt wird irgendwann kommen
barbecue restaurant zu finden sein wenn
ihr nicht gerade in buxtehude lebt und
falls doch dann passt jetzt gut auch
wenn ich zeige euch wie man das ganz
einfach zu hause machen kann schritt
nummer eins einkaufsliste schreiben
schritt nummer zwei einkaufen gehen wenn
man auf tik tok unterwegs ist unter
algorithmus weiß dass die bts max wird
er die schnell die videos aus dem game
stores zeigen asiatische supermärkte
haben zwar noch mehr als rahmen zu
bieten aber es lohnt sich definitiv da
mal reinzuschauen und neue sorten
auszuprobieren wieder zu hause
angekommen geht es auch schon los zuerst
schneide ich das fleisch in kleine
stücke und marin ihre ist das soll
nämlich lange durchziehen fleischkonsum
ist zu gering geworden dass ich ab und
zu mal für ein besonderes gericht auch
guten gewissens fleisch esse dann
bereite ich jetzt zu also jetzt gehe ich
jetzt mal einkaufen film das alles links
und so und dann bereite ich zu das
stellt die kamera vor mich hin und dann
ist das so mache ich kurian barbecue
los geht's mit der zubereitung es gibt
eigentlich gar nicht so viel
vorzubereiten man braucht noch ein
bisschen gemüse und es ist ganz ganz
wichtig was für den rand von unseren
tollen gerät zu machen und dieses mal
machen wir käse mit meissen es ist ein
koreanisches man kann aber auch zum
beispiel so was wie iran oder sogar
daran machen ich bin dafür weil wir
schon in snack laune sind dass wir die 1
viel freier heiko gies hradschin fleisch
30 packungen 2021 tik tok food mäßig für
das jetzt so einfach klingt als aus der
hölle
irgendwie ja kann nicht so richtig
trinken diesen original damit wir unsere
salatteller auch haben brauchen wir
natürlich salat und dann nehme ich so
roman herzen weil die sind gut
funktioniert und so gottes so hallo
pizza und die müssen dann so abgerückt
werden eigentlich gibt's noch besseren
salat aber ja nun wenn man kopfsalat
bisschen zu weich
also ich finde der zu labbrig um den
weiß welchen sie hat mir ins gesicht
berühren und ansonsten noch dass kim chi
in schützing vorbereiten
das ist okay wir werden das auf messen
auf jeden fall zum salat waschen könnt
ihr natürlich nehmen was ihr wollt ich
habe jetzt in der salatschleuder und
dann schleudert ihr euren sauerland
waren sie so schön aus wiesenblumen wir
bereits unseren reis vor und da muss man
immer daran denken seinen reis zu
waschen wäsche dann reiße ich es aber
auch nicht wir machen das ist eine
exzellente frage weil das gefragt ganz
ehrlich ich kann es nicht in unsere
arbeit ist richtig toll wie office regel
noch waschen der live kommentator
einfach nur so richtig groß da ich noch
einmal alles gefährlich und zu nicht
selber kann ihn aber auch nicht
juni kritisiert 24 stunden mein leben
dafür mit dem lappen vision ist das ist
ja an vielen tischen heute und jetzt mal
nicht so ein jahr zu spät auf ein
kaufpreis kommt an ein halb cups wasser
das ist die 1000 schüler ihr müsst ihr
es vielleicht anders kochen aber ich
hoffe mein reizungen preis kommen
während der reiskocher so seine arbeit
macht hinterfragen wir alle unsere
lebensentscheidungen jetzt wissen wir
alles aufbauen das passiert halt nicht
viel in der küche ist mit der lippe wie
gekocht während man ist deswegen braucht
es auch wenn so ungelenk ich geboren
[Musik]
unboxing drauf
das sind typische der salat wichtigste
glaube ich noch zu dünn geschnitten
saucen dürfen natürlich auch nicht
fehlen was mir sehr wichtig ist minsk
garlik richtiger profi ist man natürlich
mit stäbchen bz trinken
du kennst du nicht schon schuhe zuschuss
auf das kann ich noch nicht gut
vorstellen zu gebratenem fleisch wir
fangen gleich mit dem barbecue an aber
vorher müssen wir uns um diesen käse
mais rand kümmern
ich habe das noch nie vorher gemacht ich
hoffe das wird war es also uns einfach
mal gesagt hat was jetzt mal so geil
dass ich aus wie so ein krasser mit
banken channel verriet obama helfen
irgendwie so meister entweder war dass
ich schlecht ist sie derzeit oder die
beste idee aller zeiten
ich habe hole ausgegeben für käse ohne
ende gestern hatte ich circa einem
halben kilo parmesan käse gegessen was
ich und meine tolle assistentin zeigen
euch jetzt wie man kann damit richtig
soja dort gehören lange alles so lange
her du musst so bringen wir sie ja irre
weil ich respekt vor die haben genau ich
bin da war und ist so dass größere
manuell haben uns jetzt schon mal ein
salatblatt und dann mache ich ein
bisschen glauben vertiefen
[Musik]
dann kann man sich jetzt eigentlich
drauf machen was man möchte begleitet
haben und mintal ich habe noch kippte
[Musik]
ich bin noch salat schon im bezirk
schwaben.de fröhlich hieß darauf was
kriegst du noch kind bitte macht man
sich das selber
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auch umgekehrt es heißt es ist so lecker
es ist wirklich ein ich würde sagen ich
mein lieblingsessen
das ist einfach mit hotpot mit hotpot
[Musik]
zehn von zehn hier von unserer seite
ich hoffe euch das video gefallen und
ich hab euch integration gegeben weil
ich mal selber machen bestimmt zum
raclette grill auch und wir sehen uns
beim nächsten mal wieder und wir essen
jetzt gemeldet
[Musik]
richtig schlecht wieder so am geld sehen
ist wenn ich noch einen profi